tout le monde
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur en jour je viens pour
faire ma dose de rappel il ya des rendez
vous à ne pas manquer pour continuer à
vous protéger penser dès maintenant à
votre dose de rappel
[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 sixième
semaine de guerre en ukraine la guerre
d'usure la guerre des sièges a encore
franchi un cap avec la diffusion de ces
images insoutenables de cadavres abuja
dans les environs de kiev washington
paris et londres évoque des crimes de
guerre l'ukraine un génocide la russie
dément une enquête est ouverte l'union
européenne discute en urgence de
nouvelles sanctions contre moscou alors
quelle est la réponse de l'occident
faut-il franchir un nouveau seuil dans
les sanctions faut-il boycotter le gaz
russe faut-il armes et l'ukraine de
manière plus conséquente
comment gagner une guerre sans la faire
on va poser ses questions à nos invités
j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés sylvie
bermann bonsoir ambassadeur de france
ancienne ambassadrice en russie chine et
royaume uni bienvenue à vous en face de
vous nous avons pierre connaissent un
bon soir essayiste ancien haut
fonctionnaire du ministère de la défense
nous avons également en duplex feu par
sky pardon de kiev les ja vassy lenco
député ukrainienne qui est en fait dans
l'opposition et qui devrait venir
arriver dans quelques minutes on a
quelques petits soucis de connexion pour
l'instant avec kiev et nous avons
également avec nous sophie gabillaud
donc par skype sofia bio bonsoir avocate
associée au cabinet skweres également
spécialiste de sanctions bonsoir et
bienvenue avec nous tout de suite pour
démarrer ce débat eh bien je vais
d'abord eh bien on va avoir avec nous de
l'hiver craag notre correspondant à kiev
et avant de vous poser une question
justement sur votre reportage de
gulliver a bien va le regarder sur le
portage que vous avez tourné dans les
environs de kiev puisque vous avez suivi
l'armée ukrainienne
tout près de l'épave du plus gros avion
du monde le ministre ukrainien de la
défense vient récompenser ces militaires
l'aéroport d'oslo mail dans la région de
kiev avait été occupée dès le début de
la guerre
l'ukraine en a repris contrôler le
peuple de kiev prie pour vous et pour
nous et que nous les dégageons de notre
pays du fond de mon coeur merci gloire à
l'ukraine les célébrations se font dans
le calme car cette victoire a été
obtenue au prix de lourdes pertes
je ne peux pas vous dire comment c'était
ce n'est pas la victoire pour l'instant
c'est juste
ce sera la victoire quand ils sont
partis nous avons tellement peine tout
près de là de nombreuses villes ont été
totalement détruites dimanche au moins
400 corps de civils ont été découverts
dans la région de kiev mais ce quartier
semble avoir évité les pires atrocités
les russes étaient ici ils sont allés
dans chaque maison je ne sais pas
vraiment ce qu'il cherchait
depuis le 4 mars nous n'avons plus
d'électricité ni d'eau ou de gaz donc
nous devons cuisine est dehors ici
pas d'électricité signifie pas
d'information certains soldats se charge
désormais de les transmettre
les russes disent qu'ils vont prendre le
contrôle des régions de donetsk de
lougansk
donc il aurait n'escalade là bas oui
c'est inévitable mais nous sommes prêts
il affirme avoir choisi de se retirer de
cette région où nous les avons tellement
combat rider qui n'était même plus
capable de combattre ici cette colonne
militaire a été détruite il ya trois
semaines les corps des soldats russes
sont encore éparpillés autour ses
occupants rouges ont tenté d'utiliser
cette route pour se rendre jusqu'à kiev
en passant par hear pin nous avons fait
exploser ce pont ainsi que les soldats
rouges présence les membres de la garde
nationale tu comme leur véhicule il
c'est ici que nous avons stoppé
l'avancée des russes vers kiev
les ukrainiens affichent leur fierté
leur soulagement d'avoir libéré la
région de kiev des troupes russes mais
ils redoutent une chose que les russes
souhaitent prendre rapidement leur
revanche
gulliver vous êtes avec nous de quelques
hivers craag vous avez tourné à ces
images n'étaient pas votre voix parce
que ça a été reversé comme on dit dans
notre jargon mais c'est bien votre
reportage d'abord qu'est ce qui vous
frappe aujourd'hui gulliver et est ce
que finalement ces images abuja forme un
tournant de cette guerre
alors ce que je devrais souligner c'est
que nous avons vu et c'est les
militaires ukrainien qui nous entend
mener à bout de chars qui ont te peut
décider en fait ce qu'il voulait nous
montrer surtout les traces de la
bataille féroce qui a été menée dans ces
trois villes beach house tôt mais les
yvelines et la destruction de ces trois
villes qui est vraiment impressionnante
pour une grande partie de ces villes et
puis les conditions tout à fait
déplorable dans lesquelles vivent les
habitants qui sont là en ce moment qui
manquent de tout en quelque sorte mais
les corps des civils qui ont été tuées à
bout de chats et ailleurs ont pour la
plupart été enlevée déjà les militaires
n'ont pas pu trouver pour nous montrer
ce jour là mais je pense qu'il est juste
en réalité que les yeux du monde sera
fixé sur ces images plus tôt et sur ces
évidences de tueries de civils dans ces
villes je pense que il convient de
souligner que ce n'est pas tout beau
chat qui a été affecté les gens avec qui
moi j'ai parlé n'avait pas
d'informations sur des tueries comme ça
sur les russes qui qui qui tuer des gens
dans la rue mais il faut se rappeler que
manquant de connexion téléphonique
d'électricité sortant très rarement de
chez eux en fait les gens d'un quartier
de boujean n'ont pas forcément beaucoup
d'informations sur ce qui se passe dans
un autre quartier mais c'est pas tout la
ville qui a été affecté sa a pas été
systématique en ignore vraiment quelle
était la stratégie
quelle est la raison de ces tueries et
on ne peut guère se conforter du fait
que ce n'est pas tout bout de champ qui
a été affecté par ce genre de
comportement des russes puisque de plus
en plus d'informations sortent comme
quoi il y aurait eu des comportements
similaires et des tueries similaires
dans d'autres villes et villages occupés
par les russes est maintenant à nouveau
aux mains des ukrainiens selon la
procureur général d'ukraine le village
de body and if kaki un peu plus à
l'ouest de butch à la situation là bas
est encore pire ce sont les mots de la
procureure générale merci gulliver
ingénieurs crack en direct de caisse je
vous laisse à nos confrères anglophones
on va écouter tout de suite volodymyr et
l'inscrit qui s'est rendu à abuja
ce que vous voyez maintenant ce sont des
crimes de guerre c'est un génocide
et le fait que vous soyez tous ici sur
place cela vous permet de voir ce que
des milliers de personnes ont été
torturées dtcc tuer des femmes ont été
violées et des enfants tuent avec les
femmes et bien c'est cela un génocide
sylvie bermann ce que c'est un tournant
dans cette guerre je ne sais pas si
c'est un tournant parce qu'en réalité il
ya des crimes de guerre mais les crimes
de guerre ont commencé quand l'hôpital
de marioupol a été bombardée avec des
enfants dedans et c'était indiqué il y a
trois cents morts qui sont largement des
populations civiles maintenant en termes
d'émotions de la communauté
internationale oui mais sinon sur le
terrain bon geler les soldats russes
doit être absolument furieux d'avoir
perdu ça ne justifie pas leur
comportement mais c'est un peu une
vengeance est une vengeance
atroce et effectivement il ya une mère
son mari enfin maire d'une petite ville
sont mariés le fils qui ont été tuées à
un homme qui a été retrouvé au fond d'un
puits donc effectivement ça ça touche
beaucoup mais c'est
je pense que ce qu'il faudra juger c'est
aussi l'ensemble de ces guerres et qui
va se poursuivre et probablement de
manière encore plus violente
dans mario paul qui est l'objectif
maintenant de poutine et dans l'ensemble
du dombass on pourra parler de crimes de
guerre dont celles et ceux qui parlent
de génocide ce qu'il va y avoir
effectivement est ce que vladimir
poutine devra rendre des comptes alors
d'abord ce n'est pas un génocide on sait
pas évidemment à nous d'en décider c'est
au jury c'est la cour pénale
internationale
mais il ya une convention des nations
unies qui date de 1948 et qui pour la
prévention et la répression du génocide
et qui définit ce qu'est un génocide
c'est la volonté celle là l'intention de
détruire un groupe national pour des
raisons ethniques religieuses etc les
crimes de guerre sont définis également
et c'est les attaques contre les
populations civiles les enlèvements les
exécutions sommaires et autres et là ça
relève plus du
des crimes de guerre et par ailleurs
dans la convention sur le génocide il
est prévu de kylie à une intervention de
la cour pénale et une intervention de la
communauté internationale et j'étais à
new york au moment du génocide au rwanda
et les juristes américains refusent
absolument de le qualifier de génocide
puisqu'il ne voulait pas avoir à
intervenir et par ailleurs la russie
tout comme les états unis n'ont pas
ratifié le statut de rome qui a créé la
cour pénale internationale et ne
reconnaissent pas la compétence de cette
cour les ja vassil and co est ce que
vous êtes avec nous à on est toujours
pas avec nous un député ukrainien on
vous attend pierre conessa selon les ong
human right watch en tout cas des
soldats russes se sont rendus coupables
de crimes de guerre en tout cas c'est ce
qu'ils disent dans les régions de czerny
if kharkiv et kiev selon les ong donc ça
veut dire que et la cpi a ouvert
également un dossier pour crimes
d'agression crimes de guerre donc là
aussi lanières poutine vous pensez qu'il
pourra il devra rendre des comptes non
non je pense qu'il ne rendra absolument
contre rappelez-vous l'historique de la
cour pénale internationale c'est une
initiative de bill clinton pendant la
crise ans en yougoslavie
et c'est le congrès américain qui refuse
de ratifier la convention comic clinton
l'avait initié bon la suite de ça la
russie l'inde et la chine on le dit bah
écoutez donc aujourd'hui on la cour
pénale internationale n'a réussi qu'à
condamner quelques africains milosevic
et nice et fitch oui oui milosevic mais
je veux dire on est dans une espèce de
mensonges baydan veut absolument le
faire passer devant la cour pénale
internationale
il a deux très bons tout les experts
auprès de lui pour les crimes contre
l'humanité et les crimes de guerre c'est
les deux les bleus père boucher le fils
bush donc je veux dire comment est ce
qu'on peut aujourd'hui faire comme si
poutine était le premier justicière de
la cour pénale internationale
la guerre d'irak a tué cent mille
personnes et donc ça va ça signifie que
lui n'a pas de comptes à rendre parce
qu'il y avait la guerre d'irak ouais
mais je veux dire c'est nous qui devons
rappeler cet épisode c'est nous qui
devons le rappeler parce que encore une
fois cette espèce de bonne conscience
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui en dix ans
mais poutine il faut absolument le faire
presser
jeudi il faut balayer chez soi des
règles dans la guerre c'est ce qu'on a
toujours dit moi d'accord mais justement
comment les a pas respectés nous mêmes
on a du mal aujourd'hui à parler au nom
de la communauté internationale c'est ce
que nous disent un certain nombre de
pays africains et payant si lieberman ya
des règles dans la guerre il ya des
règles dans la guerre qui doivent être
respectées par toutes les armes est
effectivement mais encore une fois je
dire ça ne veut pas dire non plus encore
une fois poutine est responsable de
cette guerre d'agression sans aucun
doute mais en revanche ça ne veut pas
dire que les ordres viennent de poutine
ou même du commandement militaire à
moscou dans ce comportement des soldats
dont kylie a effectivement violation du
droit de la guerre et effectivement ceux
qui l'ont commis parce qu'il va y avoir
des enquêtes le procureur général de la
cour pénale a ouvert une enquête il ya
des dossiers qui sont
on
a semblé et comme preuve est
effectivement à ce moment là on peut
identifier les coupables mais cela dit
il faut pas non plus faire d'illusions
parce que dans la mesure où la russie ne
reconnaît pas la compétence de la cour
ça sera très difficile de les déférer
devant cette cour sanctions en tout cas
possible la france et l'allemagne le
souhaite on va écouter à le président
français
ce qui vient de se passer à butch impose
un nouveau train de sanctions et des
mesures très claires donc nous allons
nous coordonner avec nos partenaires
européens en particulier avec
l'allemagne mais je nous allons prendre
des mesures individuelles
supplémentaires et moi je suis favorable
à ce qu'on est en train de sanctions et
qu'en particulier déjà sur le charbon et
le pétrole dont on sait qu'ils sont
particulièrement douloureux on puisse
agir sa purée ce soit coordonnée au
niveau européen ce fait cabillaud
bouquet est spécialiste des sanctions
est-ce que qu'elle doit être finalement
la réponse de l'occident face à ce qui
se passait ce qu'il faut avoir augmenté
en tout cas les sanctions faire en
sortie à nouveau train de sanctions
alors que l'on entend effectivement
c'est ce qui vient d'être dit on parle
d'un nouveau train de sanctions puisque
il faut le rappeler nous en sommes au
quatrième paquet de sanctions qui a été
appliquée de la part de l'union
européenne le dernier volet ne toucher
que partiellement finlande et dernier
volet qui ne touchait que partiellement
et dont on parle particulier avant c'est
bien évidemment le secteur de l'énergie
est ici les les sanctions qui
resteraient à imposer et seront celles
de non pas des investissements de
l'union européenne et si les lignes
européennes vis-à-vis de la russie mais
cette fois-ci de l'importation de du gaz
en particulier on entendait de chars
mais aussi
de tout le secteur de l'énergie
vis-à-vis d'eux me européenne est bien
évidemment notre foi notre codépendance
enfin notre dépendance
aux ressources russes pose une
difficulté situation est ce que vous
pensez qu'il pourrait y avoir un embargo
sur le gaz russe
alors en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que c'est ce secteur qui reste le
seul dans l'escaladé sanction qu'on a vu
jusqu'à présent c'est bien le dernier
secteur à l'être en touche et on entend
aussi des sanctions individuelles donc
on comprend qu'il vraie aventure je n'ai
race de jeunesse beauport brac de
nouvelles personnes qui puisse
effectivement être être mis sur les
listes de gel mais le plus gros est ce
dont vont pas cesser culture ce que vous
évoquez c'est à dire
une sanction une interdiction plus
généralisé sur le secteur de l'énergie
gesca vassy lenco vous avez rejoint de
kiev député ukrainienne du parti avoir
bonsoir à vous bienvenue quelle doit
être la réponse de l'occident vous
prenez cette émission en route mais on
n'a bien entendu pas hélas clics ils lui
demandent des sanctions supplémentaires
est ce que les européens doivent se
passer de gaz russe
longtemps y renonce en gaz et pétrole
russe est en fait à tout ce qui provient
de la russie à tout ce que vous achetez
à ce moment en russie chaque euro va
acheter des balles et des missiles qui
tue les ukrainiens
c'est un choix bien sûr je pense pas à
ma nation européenne comme nation qui a
de la valeur à la liberté
vous ça
c'est à dire vous êtes favorable en tout
cas ce qu'il ya un embargo sur le gaz
russe en europe et bien sûr c'est ça ce
que je demande j'étais enfant cependant
ce jour
entretien avec les ministères français
avec le président de la
ccsa ce que je lui ai demandé en direct
d'imposer un embargo sur le gaz et le
pétrole russe sylvie bermann entendu à
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs ce matin
parler plutôt de pétrole pas vraiment de
gaz l'europe doit-elle effectivement
renforcer ses sanctions vous inquiète la
diplomate ce plateau je crois qu'il ya
déjà des sanctions sans précédent contre
la russie c'est très difficile sont
suffisantes on voit bien qu'en tout cas
on n'empêche pas la guerre mais je pense
pas que ce train de sanctions empêchera
davantage la guerre de la dmr poutine
est déterminé et ce n'est pas ça qui
l'empêchera d'autant plus qu'il ne s'est
jamais intéressé à l'économie et la
situation de son propre peuple et de la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat donc je pense
pas que ça aura véritablement un effet
après il ya rien morale devient effet
moral plus la guerre c'est symbolique
effectivement mais est ce qu'on peut se
permettre pour le pétrole et le charbon
on peut en france même sur le gaz ça
serait plus facile que dans d'autres
pays parce qu on a une dépendance
uniquement de 17 18% les allemands c'est
55 % par rapport au gaz et je crois 35%
par rapport au pétrole donc c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour eux et
c'est vrai que il ya un moment où ça va
être difficile d'adopter d'autres
sanctions mais autant la fourniture
d'armes à l'ukraine pour lui permettre
de se défendre
peu aidés effectivement autant mais les
sanctions je comprends pas ce que c'est
c'est eh les thoniers a boy pour les à
cameron l'estonie également donc les
pays baltes agressions très favorable la
pologne aussi pourtant pourtant
dépendante du gaz russe pierre conesa
une nouveauté quand même dans ces
sanctions c'est l'idée de viser les
oligarques ces devises et l'entourage de
poutine chose qu'on n'a jamais fait
quand les américains ont imposé
l'embargo sur les rucks et un embargo de
tous y compris des médicaments ses
enfants mourir de la rougeole
aujourd'hui on essaye de cibler
l'entourage de poutine tous ces gens qui
se sont enrichis du sur le sur le
pillage de la russie et effectivement
c'est quelque chose de très nouveau et
peut être très efficace c'est à dire que
c'est sa fille sûre si vous voulez un
certain nombre de gens qui pouvait avoir
intérêt parce que le régime sommaire ça
c'est fait l embargo sur le gaz russe
anna palumbo studio 15 rue j'y crois pas
une minute pas possible je pense pas on
n'arrivera pas à nous en tout cas mettre
un embargo si les russes veulent le
mettre où ils le mettront mais nous on y
arrivera c'est à dire que les russes
pourraient couper le gaz oui c'est ça il
couperait les gaz mais nous même être un
embargo on le voit avec le cas de
l'allemagne si vous voulez on peut pas
aujourd'hui convertir si vous voulez
vous remettre entre en activité des
centrales à charbon qui effectivement
est pas dans l'air du temps mais vous
savez quand vous pensez simplement ce
qu'on appelait le long de grade c'est à
dire la place city avec tous les avoirs
des oligarques russes avant que les
anglais les banques anglaises se met à
rechercher tous les oligarques russes on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge donc il ya
ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire que les
tic ne prend pas le dessus ça veut dire
que effectivement chacun jugera ses
intérêts et donc c'est plus simple de
parler du gaz et du pétrole que de
parler de ce véritable opération sophie
cabillaud vue qui est spécialiste des
sanctions à ce qu'effectivement ces
sanctions pourraient être efficaces
s'ils ont décrété cet embargo sur le gaz
russe à peu près 800 millions
semble-t-il correspond de se dire qu'on
ne financent plus la guerre dont il ya
l'aspect moral de la sanction il ya
l'aspect également efficacité sur
justement à dissuader peut faire la
guerre
l'efficace et de la sanction c'est
effectivement un sujet qui est qui et
qui est très controversée puisque on a
des commissions a qui sont là pour dans
l'histoire vérifier l'efficacité des
sanctions est en réalité on se rend
compte que ça ça dépend de la résilience
du pays c'est difficile de pouvoir
prévoir en amont si le pays sera
sensible à ces sanctions ce qui est
certain c'est que les sanctions c'est la
dernière alternative aux conflits armés
c'est comme ça et que c'est défini par
menus et d'une certaine manière même
s'il a ici des ceintures luz et ne sont
pas applicables comment ça puisque là
aussi du parti 2000 et depuis on est
dans des régimes de sanctions
unilatéraux qui a été prise de concert
on est quand même effectivement sur la
question de se dire eh bien les
sanctions sont la dernière solution
avant le conflit armé donc est ce que on
doit aller jusqu'au bout de ce régime de
sanctions il est en trop longtemps que
en tout cas un nouveau train de
sanctions pouvaient être mises en place
sur les individus sur une partie du
secteur de l'énergie la question de
savoir si nous irons jusqu'à
l'interdiction totale de l'importation
du gaz qu'est-ce que tu continues à se
poser vous pourrez être intéressant
aussi de la pause et en parallèle de
celle des lots techniques qui sont en
train de se faire avec l'iran puisque
les rangs pour être une alternative à
terme peut-être
même si cela prendrait quelques temps on
a en tout cas ça pourrait être une
solution alternative
justement c'est à ces limitations
d'importation à la dépendance nous
allons de la russie à un point aussi sur
lesquels vous l'avenir vis-à-vis des
interdictions sur le secteur de
l'énergie on a quand même le royaume uni
qui a
[Musique]
dans sa danse trouver jeunes de
sanctions unilatérales décidées que les
derricks l'exemption sur l'importation
d'énergie mirai jusqu'à il réajuste à
part dont moi femme de l'année 2022 donc
cette
législation qui rend cette licence qu'il
y avait juste fin 2022 nous laisserait
entendre qu'à partir de fin 2022 le
royaume uni seraient plus stricts que
pour l'instant l'annoncent l'union
européenne est de même pour les états
unis les dons qu'ils n'ont pas la
dépendance que l'union européenne a
naturellement à l'égard du lierse rue
saint jean absolument qui eux ont déjà
appris
les mesures restrictives et qui seront
applicables à partir du 2 janvier
l'essai est facile enhco finalement vous
vous souhaitez que l'europe fasse un
embargo sur le gaz russe pour des
raisons morales éthiques ou est-ce que
vous êtes persuadé que ça va dissuader
vladimir poutine de poursuivre la guerre
je suis absolument pas d'accord avec le
fait que c'est juste des raisons morales
les sanctions économiques
c'est vraiment
ça c'est une grande
armée contre l'impression russe c'est
que cette arme là il va donner résultat
un petit peu plus tard donc mais c'est
vraiment on a besoin d'avoir ces
sanctions auprès de dead d'armement en
ukraine et après cette discussion à
propos du gaz russe et tout ça je veux
poser la question à tous les européens
et aux politiciens et à ceux qui qui
prennent part dans les élections et vous
savez en europe presque chappuis a signé
des lois sur la lutte contre le
contre le climat est plein de lois
environnementales aussi donc là le gaz
et le prix massa va pas ensemble on a eu
plein
de résolution pour faire la
décarbonisation de l'europe et quelques
pays l'allemagne en plus la france
inclus
les politiciens ont toujours parlé que
ça doit être avant 2050 d'être en 2040
peut-être en 2030 mais pour faire cela
pour faire ses promesses réalisé à et
pas seulement promettre quelque chose
qui va jamais arrivé on doit dire non au
gaz au pétrole et à tous les autres un
réseau énergétique qui donne du carbon
en fin de fin donc ça servirait de cause
c'est ch plusieurs doublons et de te
faire et de faire leurs promesses
réaliser les promesses qui sont faites
pour les prochaines générations pour les
jeunes qui sont en train de voter aussi
donc vous choisissiez si vous êtes
vraiment
hypocrite au chili si vous tenez à ce
que vous avez dit est ce que vous avez
promis donc c'est un autre accent sur
cette situation c'est pas juste
l'ukraine et la russie c'est quelque
chose de plus grand sylvie bermann vous
est peut-être répondre justement ça
servirait de cause finalement à la fois
de plus financer cette guerre est en
même temps effectivement la transition
écologique pour la transition écologique
c'est peut-être plus facile sur pour la
france puisque son énergie vient en
grande partie du nucléaire en revanche
l'allemagne si elle renonçait au gaz et
l'aurait une des sources d'énergie
beaucoup plus polluante parce qu'elle
serait obligée d'utiliser davantage de
charbon et qui est quand même ce qu'il y
a deux de plus polluants donc je crois
pas que ça aurait un effet
nécessairement positif sur ce plan là
mais il ya des différences entre les
différents pays puisque nous avons
effectivement développer le nucléaire
depuis des décennies le pire connais ça
moi je voudrais quand même rappeler la
différence entre les juges les pays qui
ont voté la condamnation de la russie et
les pays qui ont décidé de ne pas
appliquer les sanctions c'est à dire
qu'à une cinquantaine de pays qui ont
disparu entre les deux votes parce
qu'encore une fois ces sanctions on se
parle à nous mêmes c'est à dire
qu'effectivement je comprends cette
députée chrétienne qui dit occident vous
occidentaux vous devez persie vous faire
ça mais quand vous pensez que vous avez
trois quarts de l'humanité qui
n'appliquent pas les sanctions on est
dans un face à face et finalement ces
gens-là nous renvoie notre
responsabilité en disant ça c'est une
guerre qui vous concerne et pourquoi
voulez vous que des pays d'afrique
soient frappés par des sanctions dans un
conflit qui ne les concerne pas donc il
faut qu'on arrête de penser nous
occidentaux qu'on ait la communauté
internationale non on n'est plus on
n'est plus la communauté internationale
mais alors du côté militaire ce qu'il
faut aider militairement l'ukraine de
manière plus conséquente on va écouter
joe biden
vous vous souvenez peut-être que j'ai
été critiqué pour avoir traité poutine
de criminels de guerre eh bien c'était
la vérité vous avez vu ce qui s'est
passé à abuja
c'est un criminel de guerre mais nous
devons recueillir les informations
nous devons continuer à fournir à
l'ukraine les armes dont elle a besoin
pour continuer à se battre et nous
devons rassembler toutes les preuves
pour permettre un véritable procès pour
crimes de guerre cet homme est violent
ce qui se passe à bout de chat est
scandaleux et tout le monde en est
témoin les siens va c est qu est ce qu
il faut justement continuer à aider
militairement
l'ukraine est ce qu'il faut le faire de
manière plus conséquente c'est à dire ce
qu'il faut livrer des systèmes de
défense antiaérienne de plus longue
portée par exemple je pense que vous
pouvez deviner ce que je vais dire bien
sûr oui parce que craint à ce moment là
l heure nous on est en train de nous
battre non seulement pour notre
indépendance et notre liberté notre
existence même mais nous on est en train
de nous battre pour les valeurs
européennes pour
comme j'ai dit pour la vie humaine pour
la supériorité des états
l'indépendance des états la liberté tout
ça ce qui est inscrit dans tes à dans
les constitutions des pays européens de
milliers de lois des conventions
ce sont des des vraies choses de leurs
effets a qui sont en train d'être écrasé
par la russie en ukraine et le prennent
ce combat pour ça on peut le faire on
peut le faire nous mêmes mais on a
vraiment besoin de moi vraiment besoin d
armement ah si vous voulez qu'on le
fasse pour vous aussi mais sinon je
voudrais
dire à tout le monde qu'ils qui nous
regardent je participe à cette
discussion que c'est une obligation
internationale selon le stif de nations
unies pour la communauté internationale
de réagir en dans le cas où il y à
l'agression d'un membre de la communauté
internationale contre l'autre
l'agression de la russie contre
l'ukraine devait déjà avoir une
intervention collective internationale
pour la paix et la sécurité
internationales ça ce n'est pas passée
et les membres là côté international
aujourd'hui font le minimum qu'ils
peuvent faire pour que le monde entier
ne soit pas si je vais dans une
troisième guerre mondiale tu es veerman
ouvrages et c'est peut-être est-ce qu
effectivement les ukrainiens font aussi
la guerre pour nous face à la menace
russe je crois qu'ils font avant tout et
c'est normal la guerre pour défendre
leur patrie c'est une guerre de
résistance et que nous ne pouvons
qu'admirer effectivement mais on peut
pas dire qu'on ne fait que minimum je
viens il ya une ligne rouge qui a été
tracée dès le départ c'est qu'on n'était
pas co belligérants et qu'on ne faisait
pas la guerre à la russie donc comme
gérant julien n'envoie pas d'armes à
longue portée de alors fini on voit pas
on ne met pas en place par exemple une
zone d'exclusion aérienne pour ne pas
tirer nous mêmes sur des sur des avions
russes en revanche l'union européenne a
quand même créé une décision sans
précédent qui est d'allouer 1 milliard
de dollars pour la fourniture au pardon
pour la fourniture d'armes à l'ukraine
sur la facilité de paix c'est sans
précédent l'union européenne n'était pas
considéré comme une une alliance ni même
une entité militaire même si l aide des
moyens c'est la première fois qu'elle le
fait et c'est pas négligeable est-ce
comment gagner la guerre sans la faire
c'est aussi un peu la question qu'on
peut se poser cela dit il faut pas
s'illusionner sur les fournitures qu'on
est capable de fournir aux ukrainiens
tout ce qui m'arrive briques des manpad
vous savez c'est à dire ces armes
individuelles et en particulier en
matière aérienne dans laquelle les rues
sont à qui il définitivement la
suprématie sont limitées en altitude
c'est à dire que finalement ça oblige
les russes a bombardé de brou plus haut
les bombardaient de beaucoup plus haut
ça veut dire ils vont s'en va être sûr
qu'ils vont encore faire plus de
victimes donc si on s'engage dans cette
voie là on sait qu'on va s'intégrer dans
une guerre de longue durée mais elle est
déjà longue il y aurait bien
reconnaissable on est allé en
afghanistan il a fallu 20 ans et encore
une fois aux
faut pas se faire d'illusions le temps
médiatique n'est pas le fond mais
lorsque les ukrainiens demande justement
ces systèmes de défense antiaérienne de
plus longue portée c'est pour en fait
mieux se protéger oui mais encore une
fois on est le temps médiatique n'est
pas le temps de la guerre c'est à dire
que cela dit on aura effectivement des
destructions mais il ya des limites à
l'utiliser ces matériels à les russes
vont adapter leurs tactiques ils vont
probablement regrouper leurs forces ils
vont faire un certain nombre
d'adaptations cette guerre sera
meurtrière pour les ukrainiens mais
aussi pour les russes et c'est un peu là
dessus qu'on espère en compte c'est à
dire que l'armée l'armée russe est aussi
composée d'appeler ses applis c'est le
scénario d le fragile si vous voulez de
gens qui vont voir leurs enfants mourir
pour une guerre qui ne comprennent pas
les services et les oeuvres y répondre
est-ce qu effectivement ça va encore
plus fragilisés les les ukrainiens que
d'être dans l'escaladé
les ukrainiens ont besoin les armements
pour nous défendre on se lève chaque
jour on dit merci à ce qu'on voit le
soleil qu'on est vivant et on continue
de nous battre je renvoie le faire
jusqu'à ce que le dernier soldat russe
ne quitte la terre ukrainienne et c'est
normal on est on croit notre victoire et
on va le faire avec vous au sens c'est
un choix que vous avez ici aussi si vous
voulez être
regardé le cren comme si c'était une
série télé et regardez
c'est une nation de 45 millions
ces deux régions pour moi des femmes d
inventer sous la dent le terrain et qui
souffrent à cause de ces barbaries tc
atrocités russes et les russes wii se
regroupent ils sont en train de le faire
il ya la phase 2 de la gare va avoir la
phase iii les pascal vous savez pourquoi
parce que poutine et le gouvernement
russes ses soldats et ses généraux ils
ont juste un but et ce but c'est de
détruire un pays indépendant et
d'exterminer le peuple ukrainien comme
une nation et comme un peu ils vont se
dire et de souligner son rival serait
enfants comme ils le font déjà et le
monde dans quel projet juste être
quelque part au side line est juste
regarder comment ça marche et si ça va
ou ça va pas aller disputer c'est à
peut-être siro vous nous donnez des des
armements plus sophistiquée que ça peut
provoquer la russie encore plus
lentilles et déjà provoqué vont pas
s'arrêter jusqu'à ce que le dernier
première ne soient pas morts on y
prennent ils nous traitent pas comme une
nation ne traite pas comme un pays il
n'accepte pas que l'ukraine est un pays
indépendant c'est ça ce que doit être
compris c'est la même chose qu'eux
étaient déjà en l'histoire des dizaines
d années avec l'ip lait réellement
est-ce que l'apaisement déplaire à
apporter la paix en novembre non ça a
provoqué une guerre mme deuxième guerre
mondiale ça se passe aujourd'hui si on
traîne le temps et on
discute et on espère que ça va être
fixée diplomatiquement donc ça va pas on
va avoir beaucoup plus des casual td
guerre on va avoir des victimes on va
voir des atrocités ils vont remonter en
nombre et de toute façon en fin de fin
cette gamme va dépasser le mort d'une
crème c'est là le moment d'arrêter
d'arrestations sylvie bermann elle va
dépasser justement les frontières de
l'ukraine c'est ce que dit justement les
c est facile ngô donc votre réaction est
ce que l'occident est trop frileux
justement dans cette histoire de ventes
d'armes en voulant empêcher justement
qu'il y ait une contagion horizontale si
je puis dire en fait contagion il y aura
peut-être c'est ce que dit les cfc lengo
encore une fois il ya des armes qui ont
été fournis qui continuent d'être
fournie et c'est absolument important de
le faire en même temps personne ne veut
rentrer dans une véritable guerre ou
dans une troisième guerre mondiale je
crois que ça a été dit très clairement
25 questions ligne roux a enfin oui
n'est pas
on la respecte et quignon l'agent fait
écho aux belligérants mais absolument
quand même les états unis qui sont
toujours un petit peu les plus prompts à
mettre de l'huile sur le feu a répété
d'ailleurs il l'a dit même avant la
guerre ce qui n'était peut-être pas la
meilleure chose à faire que les états
unis ne l'interview devrait pas et qu'on
ne ferait pas la guerre pour pour
l'ukraine ils n'ont pas entière commune
avec par ailleurs est tout à fait la
même géographie arts ailleurs
l'armée russe
n'est pas arrivé à prendre une seule
villa par personne pour le moment n'est
pas arrivé à prendre kiev réduit ses
buts de guerre sur le donbass enfin le
dombass qui va certainement payé le prix
de la guerre il est pas prêt à
intervenir dans un autre pays l'armée
russe a montré ses limites aujourd'hui
donc vous pensez que le conflit va
rester limité à vous écouter il est
reconnaissable il ya 2 il ya deux
extensions possibles du conflit la ligne
rouge nous parler si lieberman c'est
celle que l'otan imposé mais il reste il
voulait l'ex espace soviétique
c'est à dire qu'effectivement
probablement poutine fera en géorgie ou
dans un certain nombre d'états si vous
voulez dans laquelle l'extension du
conflit s'il veut s'en sortir par le
haut parce que pour une fois ci on est
dans la situation où son armée se trouve
en échec il faut qu'ils se trouvent une
posture si vous voulez de dignité donc
c'est plutôt dans cette ex espace
soviétique qui peut éventuellement
étendre la guerre mais je crois pas du
tout qu'il a envie de franchir la ligne
rouge la posture qu'on a adopté et qui
est juste c'est d'envoyer au dans les
pays frontaliers de l'otan des renforts
militaires pour expliquer qu
effectivement on ne laisserait pas faire
cette espèce de menace perpétuelle corps
poutine avait vous souvenez affichée
avec le nucléaire mais en même temps il
faut prendre une grande initiative
diplomatique c'est à dire qu'il faut
reconnaître que la russie fait partie de
l'espace de sécurité européen néo
zélandais qui a reconnu qu'il renonçait
à sa candidature à l'otan donc on fait
des pas dans le démocrate dans la
diplomatie la question est effectivement
un c'est qu'il faut qu'il soit en point
de calage 6 volts sur l'offensive
militaire et à ce moment là qu'on lui
propose une négociation qui tiennent
compte du fait que quand même le le dos
de base c'est une population russe donc
on va pas faire comme si ça n'avait pas
existé mais ça fait partie de l'ukraine
les services nm comme moi j'essaie mais
non mais non
mais le don pas on tentera vieira est
pas une population c'est s'est fait pas
partie de la russie c'est ce serait la
même chose que ce qui est si je dirais
qu rostov-sur-le-don ça fait partie de
l'ue prennent c'est une population
ukrainienne on va aller être dans
l'histoire voire
un peu plus prégnant je parle russe moi
aussi quoi je suis russe non
à vis du respect quand même pour un pays
est-ce qui aurait justement une chance
qui est des que les négociations pour se
poursuivre les investissements qu à ce
stade parce qu'on sait que il ya eu des
discussions en tout cas en turquie entre
des parties l'ukrainienne et des partie
russe quels sont vos espoirs sur le plan
diplomatique
les négociations qui sont en train de se
faire et se sont faits pendant tous les
quarante jours de cette escale à sion de
guerre
ils ont toujours autour d'eux
essaie de sauver les vies humaines
ils sont autour des couloirs vertes et
des couloirs humanitaires vraiment
nécessaire pour pour sauver les
ukrainiens qui sont infligées et en
sièges et dans des villes comme ras le
bol qu'on tirs nourris et des c'est ça
qu'on discute avec leurs huit conseils
de disputer à ceux sur le fait de
comment est-ce qu'on finit cette guerre
est tout ce qu on pourrait discuter
politiquement ça dépend de deux de
l'armée russe qui doit dérober le
territoire ukrainien et pour les russes
chaque fois c'est que non ils vont pas
le faire parce qu'ils sont en mission en
train de libérer les ukrainiens de quoi
c'est une autre question on ne peut pas
comprendre
les ukrainiens dont nous sommes un
peuple avec un gouvernement avec un
parlement avec des élections
démocratiques peut pas être une paire et
on était bien comme on était assez juste
en trois ans on a un problème avec qui a
un problème avec nous donc ça ça
n'avance pas mais à les
négociations ça se passe tout le temps
et pas plus en fait que les missions
humanitaires pour l'instant en tout cas
c'est lieberman ces options
diplomatiques
alors en turquie il ya eu des
discussions substantielles en réalité
pas uniquement sur les couloirs alors
d'abord sur les couloirs d'évacuation ça
a été le premier sujet évoqué c'est très
important pour le mans président de la
république est intervenu avec olaf
scholz le chancelier allemand auprès de
vladimir poutine il ya quand même eu des
discussions sur le fond des choses
puisque il ya cette proposition de
neutralité de l'ukraine avec des
garanties internationales et là dessus
dit mir hélène ce qui a donné un accord
bien entendu il faudra que les garanties
soient suffisamment forte et la question
du statut du donbass et de la crimée
évidemment n'ont pas trouvé de solution
mais il ya eu des propositions qui ont
été envoyées par veulent le demeurer
lansky au kremlin qui doit y répondre ça
va être à mon avis extrêmement difficile
la question de la neutralité sera sans
doute la plus facile mais il avait
proposé de mettre en suspens pendant 15
ans la question du statut du dombass
pierre connais ça je crois qu'on est
face à une situation qu'on a déjà connu
vous savez ces états fédéraux qu'on
avait créé après la guerre de 14 ou qui
sont les civils à paris avec 14 buts la
ville etc
on pensait que la fédération était un
système de gestion d'identités
différentes bon l'exploitant rappelez
vous la yougoslavie à la éclaté et on
nous avons bombardé la serbie pour
accorder l'indépendance du kosovo donc
nous qui aujourd'hui disons que le
dombass et l'ukrainien en s'aperçoit
qu'on a deux poids deux mesures c'est à
dire dans certains cas on va intervenir
mais actuellement pour obtenir la
sécession d'un pays dont basse et
d'ukraine tout de même louis ii mais
aussi de même que le kosovo c'était la
serbie donc je veux dire si on est dans
le relatif à son histoire est il fondé
s'il vous plaît on est dans une
situation qui est très compliqué ces
états fédéraux dans lesquelles les
frontières administratives sont devenus
les frontières internationales ont
laissé derrière eux des populations un
peu partout
c'est à dire que les russes sont dans
une situation où ils ont l'impression
qu'il ya 40 millions de russes qui sont
à l'extérieur de la russie et donc ils
sont dans une situation où effectivement
il tient de l'argument que nous avons
nous mêmes tenues pour défendre nos
propres ressortissants aujourd'hui on la
contradiction dans deux principes de
droit international c'est l'intégrité
territoriale des états et le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes
donc il faudra bien à un moment ou un
autre on gère diplomatiquement les
locaux par cas et pas simplement opté
unilatéralement pour un des pays les
siens 20 cm qu est-ce qu effectivement
ces négociations vont tout de même au
delà des discussions sur les couloirs
humanitaires puisque et l'inscrit à
parler du fait qu'il renonçait à rentrer
dans l'otan il a parlé de ce statut de
neutralité votre mission oui mais il a
dit qu'il va disputer tout ça après le
territoire ukrainien sera d occuper donc
libre des armées russes parce que comme
ça c'est un préalable
ah oui mais après après parce que quand
on discute de tout ces choses politiques
avec des kalachnikov qui sont unis
autour des civils ukrainien c'est pas
une vraie discussion c'est par une
négociation
ça s'appelle a vu des manipulations et
c'est vraiment un chantage c'est
vraiment du terrorisme et on doit
appeler les choses comme ils sont et je
suis vraiment étonné de d'être dans
cette conversation où il y a toujours
des gens qui
ils me disent que ne tombe pas séparés
n'ya donc ça vraiment ça va bouleverser
tellement parce que c'est la même chose
que si on dirait en plein guerre
deuxièmement galles désolé je vis
quelque chose de vraiment très populaire
mais si on me demanderait en plein air
deuxième guerre mondiale par hitler
était un peu partout dans l'europe si on
disait dans vous savez alsace et
lorraine il n'y a pas de france et par
sens et sa non pas du tout ces allemands
je pense que j'ai dit est dit que c'est
parce qu'il a dit parce que des saints
mais non c'est pas c'est pas les ruches
qui ont créé la sécession du donbass et
parce qu'il y avait effectivement un
problème ce problème c'est l'imposition
de l'ukrainien comme langue unique alors
qu'il ya 30% de russophones en u11 en
ukraine on nous a dit boxxy dans tôt
nous aurions dû amener à la négociation
c'est ce qu'on a fait les accords de
minsk 1 1 et 2 cela dit ici a eu
quatorze mille morts sur la ligne
frontière entre le dombass et l'ukraine
c'est peut-être parce que les combats
ont continué et tous ces morts ne sont
pas seulement ukrainien il ya aussi des
mots russes dont il fallait pousser
aussi kiev à une forme de négociation
qui permettait si vous voulez au donbass
de rester dans les crèmes avec des
modalités encore une fois qu'ils
respectent l'entité il n'avait pas la
pression
on va prendre les rênes avec la prime et
elle est donc passé ça ce qu'il n'aurait
pas dû faire parce que l'ukraine était
un pays indépendant avec les frontières
qu'il était
accepté par toute la communauté
internationale depuis
1991 et la russie a accepté ces fonds
car là aussi l'ukraine à ces armements
nucléaires la russie devait être un des
garants garantit la sécurité de
l'ukraine comme la france
et la russie il ya envoyé du prennent en
2014 cette guerre dure huit ans déjà pas
pour 40 jours
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
les 6 à 20 cm cohade avoir été avec ton
direct de kiev merci c'est lieberman
merci pierre connaît sa merci sophy au
cabillaud qui étiez également avec nous
pour ce débat à merci à gulliver
gulliver craag notre correspondant à
kiev et merci à vous tous leur suivi un
ça va